guillaume san priest was the only one of
the three men who appeared in court to
hear the verdicts
remy faliz and essien van gaalwen have
avoided media retention since legal
proceedings began
two years ago after they were featured
in an al jazeera documentary
an undercover reporter from the
network's investigative unit
infiltrated a branch of generation
identity in the northern french city of
lille
the far-right movement believes that
europe needs to be re-conquered
from what it sees as muslim invaders
a former generation identity activist
remy fallis
was found guilty of incitement to
terrorism and assault
he was given an eight-month jail
sentence suspended for 18 months
faliz was filmed covertly at the group's
leel headquarters
he described his dying wish to drive a
car into a crowded market
popular with muslims
[Music]
feliz's conviction for assault followed
an argument with arabic speaking
teenagers
in lille's nightlife area
wearing plastic reinforced gloves
valleys struck a 13 year old girl
charged alongside feliz was guillaume
san priest
he was convicted of assault and given a
three-month suspended sentence
he was filmed using pepper spray on the
same teenaged girl that feliz later
punched
[Music]
a third defendant etienne van halwin was
convicted
of assault and incitement to racial
hatred
he was given a five-month jail sentence
suspended for 18 months
van halwin was filmed making a toast to
the nazi party in a bar
with other far-right activists
the judge said that evidence from the al
jazeera documentary
played a key role in establishing the
three men's guild
this decision sends a clear message to
the muslims of france and around the
world
but especially in france that today we
will not accept
discriminatory acts perpetuated because
of people's religion
and in particular those towards muslims
relations between the french government
and the country's four million muslims
have been strained by a series of crises
in recent months
today suspended sentences recognize the
racist motive
and the link with far-right ideology
they may fall short
of what many muslims here would consider
justice for a racist attack
on a 13-year-old girl because she was an
arab
david harrison al-jazeera leo